MAZEVILIANRUCTURE FROME AND  DEE
IGN AND THT TONITHIRSTAVE AN LO
AT GROUND LEL FIGHTING FORWHAT .
CNN'CHANCE ANDGHE AND STORY WHIO
HALINENS EXCHANGES AUARTER FIGH.
RUSSIA'SCLIVE IMAGES AREM AG
THE SOLDIERS THEMSELVES.
THE COMMANDERS TELL USS S ARW B
HERERY DAY.
THE ROADNTY THDANGER.
EXPLNS AHEAD FORCE BE
ALL RIGHT.
CAIN
ARTILLERY FIRE AY
IN
UTFR WE'RE S
EVERYTHING WE'VE BEE, IS
THE MO FIERCELTED
PATC GROUND IN THE ENTIR
FLICT.
>> QUICKLY
E RAPIG THE LENTLESS BARRA
F T
OI T THREA
IN UNDERGR BUNKERSIKE
ESLOCAL UKRAINIA CANIAN ATTACKS
ORNING TO NIGHT,S
MEE REALROBLEM IWEHEAVILY UM HES
EDRE ARTILLE POSITION.IS TIDGE E
WE, FO UKRAINEY PANSTI TS BEIN.A
MLOONER AT THE
EVEENFROM UNDERSTEY NEED
>>
Y.
DWLA
WHAT DID YT E
HE FRONT LINES?F COURSEO
THOSE UKRAINE SOIEE TO
STAY TO FACE ON Y BA BARRA ALSOW
IS HIGH ON THE  ALLRUSSIANSPLP
INTOATTLE FOR BAKHMUT.
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RNGPROGRESS, I
HIGHCE FORD E BAMMANDERS HERE LW
WHAT ELS THEO HOLD
WHOLE F MILITA SIEG, VEHICLES,
EVERYTHING LIKTHAT.
THEY'RSIAT IT ISHE
WEAPONS ANTHMU
MAKIBETWEEN
WHETHER THISE IS WON OR  MORE WN
THE MORE THEY HAVE, THTHEY RE T
'TAC
SO SO IT WOULDAS N'T BREAK DOWNU
AROUND THE WORLD.
SE STASAFE.'S POINT ABOUT WHAT
THESE TROOPS ARE GOING
WAO THE MITAYST MARK HERTLING.
WHAT IEAKNOW Y AS
WERE.OUR REON?
>> IT.ISHRO WORLD I
WHERE TH
ARTILLER
LOGISTICS, MORAMMUNITION.
WATCHI T.
IN THIS PICTURE RIEE NUMBE
CALIBER ROUN BEING SHO
THAT MACHINE GUN.
THE BACK AND FORTHN
DEFENSIVNET FO
THIS IOMT JUST
HAPPENED SINCE THE START OF THE
WA FEBRUARY. FIGHTININ DONBAS F.
COMPUTERS WHICH I E ON THE RUSSU
HAVE TO TALK LITTLE ABOUT
PSL  COMBAT.
AS YT SAID, HE'S ABLE TO  SPENDN
THEN.
MORNING, WHICH IT IS RIGHT NOW
BE UKRAINETEMPERATURES
THOSE SAME TROOPS ARE LOOKIN
THEIAMMUNIS RUNNING R ABLEL PRE.
IT IS NOH THE ARTILLERY
PROBLEMS.
OUNDS.EKTUBES BURN OUTSO ALL.
CTORS.AND THEN YOU YCHOLOGICAL S
IN THE C SIGHTS AND
OF
CT TO MY OWN
SOME ARTILLE ATTACKS. IT WAOVER.
OPERATION IRAQI FREEE WERE DR 1.
BUT THE FIGHTSTH COMBAT
ARBITRARILY ATHAT
UNITS DID TR
OW ON THONT
LINES OF IS JU
FIGG. WILL DRAIN ONNDIVIDUALS
AND REALLY CAUSE SOM
TEMPERATURE.RLIER TO T NATO
DOES WD CUSEOF USI WINTER AS A
S
HERE? THE WEA PN
BOTH SID GNGSCIPLINE IN THE FOR.
WHIN THE
FOS A LACK OF
DISCIPLINE, A HLAVAC LEADERSHIPE
THE KINDS OFHIASSOCIATEDTHARE.
R T.
HAT WI KEEWARM. YOAY DRY.
NATO ROAINE W IS THE TYPE OF
THEMSELVES.
SARANP WRAPPED AROUNDR DAY,
TREES TOTHE  OOFRFORMANCE STANDD
BOTHES GIVUKE R IS EQUAL
THFIGHT.
BUT IT WILL
HING VERY
IMPORTANT, DURING WINTER, TH.SSF
THAT YOU C.
TELL UKRAINIANS VE
VISIEVICES THAEYIGHTTIME.